- So on your podcast,
with Nicole,
you said hot dogs are your love language.
Is that true?
Do you like hot dogs that much?
- I love hot dogs.
Yeah.
I'm a little embarrassed to talk about it,
but I love them
'cause I feel like I've talked to people
who are like, "Oh, what's the
best meal you've ever had?"
And they're like, "This pasta in Italy,"
or "Seafood by the bay".
And I'm like, "I had a great
hot dog at Magic Kingdom."
(Kelly laughs)
- [Sasheer] Really.
Actually, funny story.
Nicole was dating a guy
who worked at a hot dog shop
near my house in New York.
- Jackpot for you.
- [Sasheer] Yeah.
I mean, he left the job years later,
and then they met,
you know, happenstance,
and he was like, "Weird question.
Does your best friend
Sasheer like hot dogs?"
And she was like, "Yeah, she loves them."
And he was like, "Yeah, she
would often come alone."
And I was like, "He
didn't have to say alone."
(audience laughs)
- He didn't have to drive it like that.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Sasheer] Just say I went there a bunch,
like don't tell other people
I was there alone often.
- [Kelly] And what's wrong with that?
- Exactly.
- There's nothing wrong with that.
- Yeah.
- I wanted a hot dog.
I went and got a hot dog.
I go places by myself.
That's what happens when you're single.
- I'm an independent woman.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- If I want a hot dog,
I'm gonna get a hot dog.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] It also happens
when you're a single woman with children
and you're like, "Someone
watch them. I need a minute."
- [Sasheer] Exactly.
- I don't wanna surround
myself with people.
There are people at home.
- [Sasheer] Yeah. This
is a private me time.
Need my hot dog.
- [Kelly] I love me time.
- I had a husband whose idea of a great,
it was the middle one,
his idea of a great vacation
(Kelly laughs)
was traveling around the country
to all the baseball stadiums.
So I decided my role
was to figure out which
one had the best hot dogs.
Kansas City.
- Ooh?
- Kansas City Royals, their stadium.
Oh my God. Best.
- Good to know.
I'll have to go there.
- Yeah, really.
- I love that that was
something that y'all did.
Just go to stadiums.
That's awesome.